الله اكبر
لله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى احباب
سيدنا محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده
وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله
الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا
الله نصر عبده وصدق وعده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
الرحمن علم
القران خلق
الانسان علمه
البيان الشمس والقمر
بحسبان والنجم والشجر يسجد
والسماء رفعها ووضع
الميزان الا تطغوا في
الميزان واقيموا الوزن بالقسط ولا تخسر
الميزان
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله
الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثرا سبحان الله بكره
وسله لا اله الا الله
الله وحده صد وده ونصر عبده وعز جنده وحزم
الاحزاب
وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اه محص له الد
ولوفر
الله اكبر
الله
اكب لا اله الا
الله اكب
وله الحمد
الله
اكب
السلام
‏for
make
person
make form
pay avilable bo
[Silence]
الله30
‏make
[Silence]
‏open
اللهب اكب الله
اكب لا
ها الا
الله
الله اكب
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
لا
ال الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله
اكبح الله
كثرا
سبحان
الله
الا الله
وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده وعز جنده وحزم
الاحزاب
وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
الله اكب
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا ال الا
الله الله اكبر
الله اكب
وله
الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحم الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
لا
اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا الله
ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله
لامكم
[Silence]
12 also
make
[Silence]
‏back the right side the
justly what con
[Silence]
make
الله اكب
الله اكب الله
اكب لا
ال الا
الله
اكب الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا
اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب
وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا ايا
مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله والله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله كث ثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
لا
اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب
وحده
لا اله الا الله
ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
اك
[Silence]
100000 make
that
‏st
[Silence]
care
‏clate to
come
par
[Silence]
‏make
sister
make الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته ان شاء الله اكسبلين اور صلاه
العيد ان شاء الله والفلو امام ابو حنيفه
ورحمه الله تعالى
عليه ان شاء الله سابدا
بشرح صلاه
العيد وستكون صلاه العيد على مذهب الامام
ابي حنيفه النعمان بن ثابت الكوفي رض الله
عنه
وارضه السلام علم براد و خواه عزز افغان
به نزد انشاءالله ما صلاه ع سع الفطر را
آغاز
انشاءالله صلاه العيد سنبدا بتكبيره
الاحرام ثم بعد ذلك ثلاث تكبيرات زوائد
نرفع فيها ايدينا عند
التكبير
بالعربي صلاه العيد سنبدا بتكبيره الاحرام
ثم بعدها ثلاثه تكبيرات زوائد ترفع فيها
يدك ثم بعد ذلك نقرا سوره الفاتحه وسوره
معها
تكبيره سوره الفاتحه
نت صلات ع س الفطن و سبحان ماخان باز اول
تبرم الله اكبر سبحان ماخان سه تبر قفته
مشه بعد از او الحمد شف تلاوته بعد از او
سوره ر تلاوته ما مرم به ركوع بعد دو سجده
مشه بعد از سجده سس بالاش باز در رعت دوم
اول سوره فاتحه تلاوت مشه بعد از صورته از
قرآن تلاوت مشه بعد از او باز سه تبرات
قفته مشه تبر جهارم ما مر به
رع الركعه الثان سون
بالعس
ر سوره
الفاتحه
تبهب ففتم در رعت دوم هست اول الحمد شف
قرات مشه ب سوره ازلام
قرآن تلاوت مشه بع هم سه تبرات قفته مشه
در تبر جهارم ما به ركوع
مرم استق ال الصلاه يرحم
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الرحمن
علم
القران خلق
الانسان علمه
البيان الشمس والقمر
بحسبان
والنجم والشجر
يسجدان
والسماء رفعها ووضع
الميزان الا تطغوا في
الميزان واقيموا الوزن بالقسط ولا تخسروا
ميزان والارض وضعها
للانام فيها
فاكهه والنخل ذات
الاكمام والحب ذو العصف
والريحان
فباي
الاء
ربكما
تكذبان الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم ما مالك يوم
الددين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى
والذي اخرج المر
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من
يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا
قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف ابرا ابراهيم
وموسى
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لله الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد الحمد
لله الحمد لله ثم الحمد
لله ما توفيقي ولا اعتصام
ولا ثقتي الا
بالله عليه توكلت واليه انيب حسبي الله
احمده تعالى حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا حمدا يليق بجلال وجهه وكمال صفاته
وعظيم
سلطانه يا ربنا لا نحصي ثناء عليك انت كما
اثنيت على نفسك واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له له الملك وله الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء قدير واشهد ان سيدنا
وحبيبنا
وشفيعنا وقدوتنا محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى
الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الغمه تركنا على
المحجه البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا
هالك صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين
واصحابه اجمعين ومن سار على
نهجهم الى يوم الدين
رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين فيا عباد الله اوصيكم ونفسي اولا
بتقوى الله تعالى وطاعته ولزوم اوامره
وكثره مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم
ترحمون ايها
المؤمنون اما بعد شرع الله سبحانه
وتعالى لامه سيدنا محمد صلى الله عليه
واله
وسلم عيدا يفرحون فيه
بفطر بعد
صيامهم وسن
للمسلمين صلاه
العيد وذلك بعد انتهاء
رمضان وهي من تمام ذكر الله سبحانه
وتعالى قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولتكملوا العده ولتكبروا الله على
ما
هداكم
ولعلكم
تشكرون
رمضانر
[Silence]
‏that the number
days الله سبحانه وتعالى
تكبير الله اكبر
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
لذلك شرع التكبير عند انتهاء الصيام بهذه
الايه
الكريمه فمن اجل ذلك مضت السنه بان يكبر
المسلمون عند الخروج الى صلاه العيد ويكبر
الامام في خطبه
العيد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر عيد
سمون وقوله
تعالى ولعلكم
تشكرون يقول ابن عاشور رحمه الله تعالى في
التحرير
والتنوير في تفسير ق قه تعالى ولعلكم
تشكرون في هذه الايه الكريمه قال هو تعليل
اخر وهو اعم من مضمون جملتي ولتكبروا الله
على ما
هداكم فان
التكبير
تعظيم يتضمن
شكرا والشكر
اعم لانه يكون بالاقوال التي فيها
تعظيم الله سبحانه
وتعالى ويكون ويكون بفعل القرب من الصدقات
في ايام الصيام وايام الفطر ومن مظاهر
الشكر ايها الاحبه لبس احسن الثياب يوم
الفطر
ماستر وان الله سبحانه
وتعالى
[Silence]
‏more
glor
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
التكبير
[Silence]
وهوش
الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتالى
عيد
رمضان الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولعلكم تشكرون اي اذا قمتم بما
امركم الله من
طاعته باداء
فرائضه وترك
محارمه وحفظ حدوده
فلعلكم ان تكونوا من الشاكرين
[Silence]
بذلك
حديث ان
اعرابيا قال يا رسول
الله اقريب ربنا فنناجيه
ام بعيد فنناديه
فسكت النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم فجاءت الايه بعد هذه الايه واذا سالك
عبادي
عني فاني قريب اجيب دعوه الداعي اذا
دعان ان ذس
حديث ابدو مان حضره النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى
call محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى ايه لعلكم
تشكرون واذا سالك عبادي عني فاني قريب
محمد صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم امام احمد بن حنبل رحمه الله
تعالى انس رضي الله عنه
س صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول الله تعالى انا عند ظني عبدي بي
وانا معه اذا دعاني
الله
الله امام احمد رحمه الله تعالى
مسند ابو سعيد رضي الله
عنه بفت صلى الله عليه وسلم ما من مسلم
يدعو الله عز وجل
بدعوه ليس فيها اثم او قطيعه رح
الا اعطاه الله بها احدى ثلاث
خصال اما ان يعجل له دعوته واما ان يدخرها
له في الاخرى واما ان يصرف عنه من السوء
مثلها قالوا يا رسول الله اذا نكثر قال
الله اكثر قال الله اكثر بمعنى
ان الله تعالى كلما سالته اكثر سيجيبك
اكثر
الله
الله gr
himation save it for
him
الصحابه رضوان الله تعالى عليهم
اجمعين
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى
دعاء صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى امام
احمد
سنن
الترمذي النسائي ابن
ماجه ابو هريره رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ثلاثه الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يوم
الجائزه الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الصيام
الصيام محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ثلاثه
لا ترد
دعوتهم الامام
العادل والصائم حتى
يفطر ودعوه
المظلوم يرفعها الله دون الغمام يوم
القيامه وتفتح لها ابواب
السماء يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
بعزتي لانصرنك ولو بعد حين
نسال الله تعالى ان ينصر اخواننا
المظلومين في
فلسطين ان ينصرهم نصرا عزيزا
مؤزرا يعز به الاسلام والمسلمين وان يرحم
شهدائهم وان يشفي
جرحاهم وان يعوي مبتلا
ونازحين حديث
محمد صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم
الله
‏open
الله ايها
المسلمون من رحمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى
بعباده وبام محمد صلى الله عليه
واله ان شرع لنا
اعيادا للفرح
والسرور ولنا الاقتداء برسول الله صلى
الله عليه واله
وسلم باكل ثمرات قبل الذهاب الى المصلى في
عيد الفطر وعلى المسلم ان يحذر الغفله
ان يحضر الغفله عن ذكر الله تعالى
وشكره وان يعمر هذه الاوقات
بالطاعه وفعل
الخير ولا يدرك فرحه العيده في قلبه الا
الصائمون وبقدر
العباده تكون السعاده
القلبيه ات از الله ميرسي ابون اس
الصيام حضره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الفطر
الله سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه
وتالى
times obedience and do
good
those the
of in
their
and of worship
is
ريس
انور وين وف حضره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم انذا عيد
الفطر شرع لنا زكاه
الفطر زكاه الفطر طهره
للصائم ومواساه
للفقير وزكاه الفطر واجبه على كل مسلم
ذكرا او انثى صغيرا او
كبيرا ويكفي لاستقرار
وجوبها ان يفضل عن قوت المسلم وقوت من
تلزمه نفقتهم يوم العيد
وليلته بمقدار صدقه الفطر وقد علل ابن
عباس رضي الله عنهما وجوبها فقال فرض رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم زكاه الفطر طهره
للصائم من اللغو
والرفث
وطعمه
للمساكين
للمساكين والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
اغنوهم عن السؤال في هذا اليوم وفيها ايضا
اي صدقه الفطر اظهار شكر نعمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى باتمام الصيام والقيام وفعل ما
تيسر من الاعمال
الصالحه زكاه
الفطر
زكاه
[Silence]
الفطر
سد زكاه الفطر ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما الله صلى الله عليه
وسلمو زكاه
الفطر
[Silence]
الله
وقد ذهب جمهور العلماء والفقهاء
الى ان صدقه الفطري
صاع من جميع الاصناف التي يجوز اخراج
الفطره منها مما يقتات ويدخر من غالب قوت
المزكي وقوت اهله مثل التمر والارز
والشعير
والصاع اربعه انداء
[Silence]
علماء ذا
فود ذا
زكا وقد ذهب علماء
الحنفيه يجب ان
نبين للناس اقوال
العلماء والذي يفتى فيه في زماننا هذا هو
قول
الحنفيه رحمهم الله تعالى وهو قول البخاري
رحمه الله تعالى في الحديث الصحيح
وايضا هو قول ابن عمر وهو قول عمر بن عبد
العزيز الخليفه الخامس وايضا هو قول للنبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم عندما بعث معاذا الى
اليمن فبعث معاذ
صدقه الفطر والزكاه
قماشا
بعثه شاا ولم يبعثه
مطعوما يجب ان نفهم
السنه يجب ان نفهم السنه ويجب
ان نبين المصلحه في ذلك الزمان
والمكان وهذا مراعاه لحال
الفقير ليتيسر له شراء ما يريده في يوم
العيد وكذا هناك قول لابن عبد البر رحمه
الله تعالى وهو قول الامام قول للامام
مالك رحمه الله تعالى وعن طائفه وعن طائفه
من اصحابه انه تجزئ القيمه عمن
اخرجها في زكاه الفطر
سكر
زاه
[Silence]
الفطر عيد ابن عبد البر رحمه الله
تعالى
الله زكاه
الفطر
الرماء
زكاه
الفطر
درهم
صحابه امام ابو حنيفه رحمه الله
عليه اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله العظيم
لي ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين
ويا فوز الم فرين استغفروا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله بكره واصيلا لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده واعز جنده
وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا الله ولا نعبد
الا اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب سيدنا محمد وعلى
ازواج سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه سيدنا محمد
وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
كثيرا اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي
كلمتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم انصر
اخواننا في
فلسطين وفي كل مكان يا رب العالمين امين
اللهم ارهم الحق حقا ووفقهم اتباعه وارهم
الباطل باطلا ووفقهم
اجتنابه اللهم وفقهم للعمل بكتابك وسنه
نبيك محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم اللهم ولنا
خيارنا ولا تولنا اشرار ولا تحاسبنا على
ما فعل الشفاء منا اللهم اغفر لنا ما
قدمنا وما اخرنا
وما اسررنا وما اعلنا وما انت اعلم به منا
اللهم تقبل
صيامنا اللهم تقبل صيامنا اللهم تقبل
صيامنا اللهم تقبل قيامنا اللهم تقبل
نفقاتنا اللهم تقبل صدقاتنا برحمه منك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب عفو
فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فاعف عنا عافنا اللهم واعف عنا وعلى طاعتك
عنا ومن شر خلقك سلمنا والى غير بابك سيدي
لا تكلنا وعلى الدين والايمان الكاملين
جمعا توفنا نلقاك وانت راض عنا غير غ
اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين اللهم
اشف جرح المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم عاوي
النازحين بكرامتهم يا اكرم الاكرمين يا ذا
الجلال والاكرام ليس لنا رب سواك فندعوه
يا حي ويا قيوم برحمتك نستغيث لا تكلنا
الى انفسنا طرفه عين ربنا اغفر لنا
ولاخواننا الذين سبقونا بالايمان ولا تجعل
في قلوبنا غلا للذين امنوا ربنا انك رؤوف
رحيم ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين
اماما ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اخواني زينوا اعيادكم بالتكبير وكل
عام وانتم بخير نسال الله تعالى ان يتسلم
منا رمضان مقبولين
وان يسلمنا رمضان القادم اعواما عديده
وازمنه كثيره انه مجيب
الدعاء الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
عل السلام
عليكم
[Silence]
ان شاء الله الحج ان شاء الله يا
رب
[Silence]
علب الله السلام عليكم
يونس
عليكم
[Silence]
الح
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله
السلام
[Silence]
‏so pleas
make
[Silence]
‏conu more class for the now the second
part of that announcement that as you
know any st
any
quad
‏st any and
requ opportunity make
transad
and 000 in that fund right now you have
contributed
000 and and sister our is to at reach
100000 by
‏make take
[Silence]
care take care
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا
اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكب
لا
الله
الله اكب
والله
لا
الله
الله اكب
وله
اللهث والمد
لله
الله
صدق وعده ونزر عبده وع سده هز
العزب ع لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
ال مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد
وعلى
وواب
سيدنا محمد
وسواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذر
سيدنا محمد و اواب
سيدنا محمد
[Silence]
ك
‏of so any
make
second
aread more
class
[Silence]
comm comm so are
pr of you
make
opp pleas make
putable
‏you can at participate
with whatever you to do there
facility avilable the credit c you can a
check you canay whatever form you think
you can do i want make that everybody
understand one other thing that is free
of charge to all of us avilable
anybody any taes to the st of arizona
the st of ariza allows you to
‏sch
prad
you from st
of
so
[Silence]
الله اكب الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحم
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
وله
الله
اكبر اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكب
الله
اكب الا
الله اكب
وله
الله
اكب
لا
الا
الله اكب الله اكب
وله
الله اكب
لا الا
الله
الله اكب الله اكبر
ولله الحم
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحم الله اكبر
كثيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا
اله الا الله وحده وق وعده ونصر عبده واعز
جنده وهزل
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا الله
ولا نعبد
ال
ايا مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا
[Silence]
‏minut
‏areil sister gu down
up
sister
[Silence]
شا
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحم الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
سينا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده وعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذ
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمدسلم
تسليما كثيرا
كثرا
[Silence]
‏make
‏ii one
can for those who do not have a in the
back up in
the
[Silence]
‏okays
‏i
[Silence]
back brother if
standing
اخواني في مكان
بالمجال بالقاعه الكبيره في مكان كبير في
القاعه
الكبيره في صاله الجيم في صاله
الجيم اولي او اوكي في هذا المكان في
المدخل ايضا في مكان في المدخل تبع المسجد
مكان كبير
جدا الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب
وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى
امريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا
الا
الله اك
الله اكب
لام
[Silence]
‏make
‏so
don pleas so
conv
‏clad our
desire so need mak are take care of this
great
place to make lear very
ear to
‏emy it com from
own of
stund for ofic sch pr
schad
[Silence]
‏take
‏re
back st ta we have so
80 right now you can
20 2023 ta not cl ta 203 you can
contribute
[Silence]
‏comp
80 again s small
[Silence]
‏take
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا
اله الا الله الله الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
وله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا اياه
مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله
[Silence]
اكبر
‏one
[Silence]
الله heel one the
front
[Silence]
‏do
‏one more
[Silence]
right
‏let me qui
exp ان شاء
الله
طريقه امام ح رحمه
ركعه
اجما الله اكبر
تبق
[Silence]
‏people re
‏sister ‏make
as time
fors be
me
commitment in the g pleas down and the
ps you cann in
the
شاء
الله
الحمدلله
خص
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكب اعذ بالله مني
الرم بسم الله
ال الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط الم
م صراط الذين انعمت
عليه غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله
الرحم ويل لكل همزه
لمزه الذي جمع مالا
وعدده يحسب ان
مه
اخلده
كلا
لينبذن في
الحطمه
وما ادراك ما
الحطمه نار الله
الموقده
التي تطلع على
الافئده
انها عليهم
مؤصده في
عمد
ممدده الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
وك الله
اكبر
اكر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر ا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مال يوم
الدين اياك
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
بسم الله
الرحم اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت
الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره ان
كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر السلام
عليك
السلام
اشهد اللهم
صل
اللهلا
ربنا
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اوكي شيخنا
تكبيرات الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ياك لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر ال الا
[Silence]
الحمد لله الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مضل له
ومن يدلله فلا هادي
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صفي بخلق
وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وعد الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف الله تعالى به غمه وجاهد في
الله حق جهاد حتى اتاه اليقين الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
والله اكبر ولله الحمد
[Silence]
‏s
يا معشر
المسلمين علم ك انتهى شهر
رمضان فان حق الله لا
ينتهي كما قال الله عز وجل واعبد ربك حتى
ياتيك
اليقين الرب الله رب رمضان وهو رب شوال
وهو رب ذو كعده وهو رب ذو الحجه وهو رب كل
شهر قال عليه الصلاه والسلام
سبحان
الله رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان الله فرض
فئ فلا فلا تضعوها وحد حدود فلا تعتدوها
وحرم اشياء فلا تنتهكوها وسكت عن اشء رحمه
لكم غير النسان فلا تبحثوا عنها او كما
قال عليه اللاه
والسلام منط
رمضان الله سبانه
الله
سبحانى محد صلى الله عليه وسلم الله
سبحانه فعبد ربك حتى يات اليقين او محمد
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحان
وتالى عليه
اللاسلام الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏as ى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبح
[Silence]
الله سبحان
صلا حث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم من صام رمضان ثم
اتبعه سته من شوال كان
ال
days
i6
[Silence]
سانتال
الله
الله حث رسول صلى علسلم ابو حرير ر الله
عن رسول الله
صلىم الاثنين
والخميس انء
الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى الله
سانال الله
سبهالى
فبحال
الله سبحانه
وانهالوا ما تسمعون واغفر الله لي ولكم
وساء المسلمين كل ذمب فاستغفر انه الغفور
الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله الله اكب
الله اكب الله اكب لا اله الله اكب
[Silence]
ومد
‏andare
because
not
days
present
الله حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا تقوم ساعه حتى يتقارب الزمان فتكون سنه
كالشهر وشهر كجمعه وتكون الجمعه كاليوم
ويكون اليوم كساعه وتكوم ساعه كال ضرمه
بالن ح رسول الله
[Silence]
‏year
‏up
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
صل
عليهه
[Silence]
صل
‏sally
[Silence]
‏mindful
الله
سانتال swift and
las for those and
sister
سانى
الله
سالق
سال
[Silence]
الله
مح
ر ال الله محد رول
الله
الثول الله صلى الله
عليه
any
[Silence]
‏make
الله
‏people
are
people are
other ands
around those and sisters are
[Silence]
‏and
الح
[Silence]
حث
وم وعيدكم مبك والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
على
شا عليكم
السلامي
[Silence]
عل
السلام ورحمه الله
[Silence]
وبكه
‏som
السلام
[Silence]
علكم
لا لا لا
كل عام وان بخير كل عام وان
[Silence]
بخير
وال
[Silence]
رب